just before president-elect Donald Trump
assumes the presidency well actually he
assumed that a while ago but before he
is officially inaugurated as president
of the United States President Obama and
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
have joined together to permanently ban
offshore drilling for fossil fuels in
Arctic waters in yet another completely
logical move that really should not be
controversial which is of course angered
the globalist establishment fossil fuel
oligarchs of the American right this ban
applies not only to Arctic waters but
also some waters uh in the Atlantic
Ocean as indefinitely off-limits for oil
and gas leasing and the logistics are
slightly different in Canada versus in
the u.s. so in canada uh there's a
moratorium subject to periodic review in
the US president obama has actually used
a law a provision in a 1953 law to ban
offshore leases permanently it's called
the 1953 outer continental shelf lands
act and that statute says that quote the
president of the United States may from
time to time withdraw from disposition
any of the unleased lands of the outer
continental shelf now the understandable
and completely logical concern given how
we know American politics works is that
as soon as Donald Trump is president of
the United States he will just undo this
but it appears that this provision has
the language and the legal precedent to
withstand trump coming in and just
reversing at the language of the statute
used to justify the ban doesn't provide
for any authority for subsequent
presidents to cancel or to unban these
waters from future oil and gas leases
and even if Trump did want to challenge
it Pat it would probably be tied up in
court for years no matter what he could
try to challenge this but it could be
four or even more years before it was
ever determined where what the path
forward would be in a court of law he's
also trying to put on this stream
protection rule to limit coal mining
near waterways and we would have to see
if Trump odd news that too
yeah we've talked a little bit more
about coal because although Trump has
talked Bigley about wanting more coal
development the market situation in
terms of oil gas natural gas and coal
pricing right now does not really set up
a scenario where we would see a huge
explosion in coal usage but yes Trump
has also talked about being in favor of
that as far as the atlantic ocean waters
that are also removed from motor be
copying called drillable areas uh range
from being off the coast of New England
in the Atlantic Ocean right here all the
way south to virginia now of particular
relevance to the incoming administration
uh I want to remind you that in 2011 on
behalf of ExxonMobil the incoming
Ludicra deck Secretary of State Rex
Tillerson Exxon CEO signed an agreement
with Russia for drilling in the Arctic
that could be valued up to 300 billion
dollars to be super clear if you look at
a map of the Arctic it sort of divided
up different countries have claims to
different parts of it of course the Rex
Tillerson deal was going to be in an
area that Russia has jurisdiction of and
here we're talking about the areas that
Canada and the United States
respectively have jurisdiction over but
this is no small thing because Donald
Trump has vowed this domestic energy
revolution he's filling his cabinet with
nominees who are very much opposed to
all of the environmental and climate
change actions that President Obama has
taken and he's also said he wants to
open up more federal land this is Donald
Trump more federal land to oil and
natural gas production to try to boost
the United States these types of
regulations and declarations from
President Obama on his way out may
actually have a really significant
impact on what Donald Trump is able to
do now back to reality for a second
after the good news a cynical
perspective a skeptical perspective
maybe a rational perspective is that
unless we get rid of fossil-fuel
reliance altogether just a matter of
time it's more when not if we continue
to harvest oil and gas in more and more
places and if you look at the map of
which countries
control the North Pole as I mentioned
the u.s. only controls a fraction of it
many other countries have access and
climate changes making it easier to
actually go to some of these parts and
drill in the North Pole if the
environment is making it easier for
people to show up extract resources and
make money we have to assume that
they're going to be really strong
corporate influences at play that are
going to do everything they can to dig
up those resources we'll keep an eye on
it in the short run a good news good
good action taken by President Obama and
Canadian Prime Minister Justin Trudeau
thanks for watching this video before
you watch the next one remember we're
raising money to expand the david pakman
show big league as well as expand
progressive activism go to david
pakman.com slash donate donations of any
size are much appreciated